I want to jump to this story give you
guys some uh some optimism here cyclists
no show post-race Podium after
biological mail finishes first and
female race that's the story take a look
at this picture the women refuse to show
up
so I think this is the start of
something good there's a another story
that we have I think it's uh maybe it's
this one
losing to a trans writer hurts on a
million different levels 24 year old
cyclist abandons Olympic dream after
sickening losses to biological male and
protests from antifa Gun Club not only
that that's terrible but apparently this
uh biological male who won physically
attacked oh yeah another writer this is
in yes this is this is wild
um there's a video from uh was posted on
April 26th it's from cyclocross yeah
cycle across and the the biological male
Riley Gaines tweeting it physically
attacks and tries to knock down a woman
and then that woman never races again
yeah crazy see they don't they they find
all the ways to get the performance in
enhancing drugs out of them so now they
just have to go and compete against
women well I mean take a look I mean
this is uh uh good for these women I've
been saying this yeah stop showing up
that's a dude and so this is a
biological male who won the women's
cycle uh race and the other women are
like the females are like no we're not
gonna We're not gonna go on the podium
it's also like remember when um they had
it was uh Leah Thomas one but then the
other one refused to stand next to Leah
Thomas I think that might have been
Riley Gaines right not entirely sure if
that was so this is this is the kind of
stuff that I'm talking about with I
don't think the left I left ideology can
actually survive it's like saying you
can build a you can build a building
imagine these people tried building a
building
and just imagine what happens I think
everyone goes oh okay now I understand
like it's not gonna stand up it's gonna
be crooked it's going to be slumping
over on one side and it may stand for a
little bit they may have guards
surrounding it with guns they may not
let you come in they may in fact kick
you out of your own building nearby but
sooner or later that thing comes
crashing down because there's there's a
logic in order to building a system
they can come out and claim all you know
what's happening
these people started building a
structure and then all of their friends
are going your structure is so amazing
it's although you don't who needs
i-beams we don't need support columns
like what are you talking about and then
they're like very happily toting along
building this thing and then one day
just crumbles because no one actually
believes it they're just trying to keep
their head down nobody wants it's the
emperor having no clothes nobody wants
to be the person to tell the king he's
naked well that's what happened with
Chernobyl no one wanted to say hey
there's a problem they were afraid to
tell people and because of that that
made the the Meltdown you know so much
worse I I if I understand correctly the
Meltdown could have been uh could have
been prevented if they would have
actually had the uh the balls to tell
the people in charge that there was a
problem but they were afraid to tell
that there's a problem with the with the
nuclear reactor nobody wanted to be that
person who was removed from the
photograph was Stalin yeah exactly I
don't know what that guy you know guys
what was his deal you know that Meme
though right yeah I don't know I don't
know what what the I don't know the the
particular story behind but I know that
that's impressive multiple people that
happened to multiple people yeah he
would de-person them and have his
artists like the Soviet artists just go
through and remove them and repaint the
picture just like we do now with like a
smartphone and like in like Photoshop
Etc just literally do Photoshop in 1930s
and that's that's actually impressive
back then you know what I mean it's
great I mean essentially that's what
canceling is now it's it's the same
thing it's the same idea it's it's a
little bit different than you know
actually killing people but like when
you cancel someone you remove them from
polite society and they're you know
their pariahs and people don't want to
associate with them and and so it's it's
the same thing but a digital but in a
digital you know world as opposed to
just see like an actual clone stamp tool
in the 1930s to just remove people from
the portrait that's amazing it's really
impressive I mean to your cancel culture
point though like I feel like more
things like this happening is
effectively you know canceling this
trans ideology that's running rampant
across our country and I think as
conservatives for a long time we've been
very scared to kind of embrace cancel
culture but I honestly think you know
there are some things that we should
cancel there are some things that are
not conducive to like good Society
cancel culture was always the left
digging up a tweet from someone from 10
years ago and getting them fired right
and so then we saw stuff like Mike
cernovich pulling up jokes from James
Gunn and then James Gunn got suspended
he got fired hired back that's it's not
cancel culture to be like hey we don't
want women's sports to be dissolved
right but I do think you know we've
bought into this fallacy of like the
marketplace of ideas and every opinion
should be heard and it's a great opinion
opinions like this you know are damaging
to people it should not be heard it
shouldn't be told dear children are
encouraged in schools or anything like
that so you know I think there always
will be some Orthodoxy that's enshrined
in the Public Square there is no such
thing as like living Let Live do what
you want something is going to dominate
the culture so we need to make sure that
what's dominating the culture is
something that's good and going to
encourage our society to you know just
like do well and to help people and and
let people live freely and and great I I
agree to a great deal I I I'll push more
on the freedom of speech component of
this in that we don't we don't want
these people secretly indoctrinating
kids we want them to come out show the
book and then we can be like and here's
why they're wrong because otherwise
they'll find creepy ways to do it but I
suppose the fair point is it's better
that you remove most overt ways of doing
it and then they're probably in the
shadows even right now you know what I
mean so I think my my realization came
when um partly from a lot of this that
it doesn't matter what your principles
are it matters where your moral line is
so the left argues they think parents
have the absolute right to determine
what's best for their kids
but then they don't care that schools
are saying don't tell your parents the
right says parents have the absolute
right to determine what's right for
their kids but the government should
intervene if a parent tries to give
their kid a sex change both groups will
argue a similar the same sentence but
then perform it in different ways and
it's it's similarly after Scott at to
how Scott Adams says we're all watching
one screen but seeing two different
movies if that's the case you have to
realize
moral framework is what unites a people
I mean I think if no culture you have no
country yeah and that's completely true
right now in the United States there's
no cohesive culture I mean we can't even
agree on what a woman is so yeah no
there's no founding value system that
everybody prescribes to but this is what
we have to realize we can agree on what
a woman is it's just that there is a
psychotic death cult that can't but why
are we acting like we're on par with
them imagine you were the CEO of a large
media company and the guy who runs the
hot dog stand downstairs starts
demanding you debate him because he's a
CEO as well it's like well well come on
look man I'm managing 3 000 employees in
this building we're managing assets in
the billions of dollars you have a small
business which I respect but you you are
not in a position where you're going to
tell me so this guy running hot dog
stand is like you're completely wrong
about interest rates let me tell you and
it's like
look man
your ideas about what an interest rate
is he comes out he says interest rates
are not mathematical they're
alphabetical and you're like okay that
makes literally no sense well I insist
it's true that a bunch of his buddies
show up in demand you do a TV interview
debate no no no no no come on if
somebody wants to come out and argue
they don't know what a woman is or make
some nonsensical claim we should just be
like you are a fringe group of people
this is the argument they make don't
platform these people it's like I'll say
the same thing back why should we
entertain their opinion
it's tough because I was again I was
just having the same kind of
conversation today with a friend and
he's like you know he had an issue with
me complaining about Communists which
suppressed president complaining about
communism weird but
um he had an issue and he's like well
you know blah blah blah this person that
person he starts talking about the right
having uh the the extremist far right
having access to power and I'm like what
are you talking about the extreme is far
right and then he's like well Tucker
Carlson and and uh Alex Jones and and
it's like these people are not Extreme
as far right he's associating them with
Nazis and he's saying well you know uh
you know that Nazi kid had dinner with
uh with Trump and it's like well Trump's
kind of a for doing that that was
a terrible idea Milo's the guy that made
it happen but like
the idea that the far right actual Nazis
have influence in the culture is to me
ridiculous like everybody has their
Spider Sense super tuned in for Nazis
but no one does for communist but he the
way he sees it is like the Communists
are all Fringe and they have no power
I'm like AOC and Bernie and you know
there's one simple way to test whether
or not the right is the call to the left
but this speaks to the the two the the
one movie two different screens well so
so I thought about this a long time ago
I'm like you know these people keep
saying Trump supporters are all in a
cult and I'm like well I I want to make
sure there's a check on my reality I I
don't want to be trapped in a bubble am
am I wrong on this one
let me let me ask you Kingsley do you
think that you can be a conservative and
pro-choice
no most conservatives I ask say that
they say that that's like one of that's
like the hardest line on what makes a
conservative
the left literally argues with me
calling me Far Right despite my opinion
on abortion being traditional Democrat
pro-choice
yet conservatives will be like oh that's
the liberal position we'll have a
conversation will disagree Sheamus and I
will make jokes all day and then
disagree on very strong issues
if you understand the differences
between
a conservative and me you're not an
occult
but the left can't tell the difference
at all they see everybody in this room
and they see far right it's the meme
yeah where they're in the they're
they're in the Communist tanky corner
and everyone else is a Nazi and it's
like if you can't see the difference in
politics between Brett me Luke
Ian James I mean Luke and Sheamus's
politics are also very very different
and we come on this show we have
eclectic voices and then we talk about
it they can't tell the difference I
spent the I spent half the day with like
my my mentions full of like cowboy come
Hunter Fans complaining of that because
I made a joke about you know about him
and and the other time was arguing with
a left-leaning guy about me being
associating with far-right people while
the far right you know the the Nazis are
in my in my mentions calling me a Jew
lover like literally just like you're a
Jew and I'm like oh I don't have a
problem with Jews but I'm not Jewish no
I love that yeah the the person who kept
super chatting being like when when will
you answer someone did a review and
found that like 25 of all the guests on
the show are Jewish or something like
that I don't even know that's true and
they're just like can you explain this
and I'm like what like what do you mean
explain it was there was there a number
that was the correct number right look
look if you think there are too many
Jewish people on timcast IRL up your
game do something worthwhile and get on
Tim cast IRL stop complaining that there
are people that are doing things that
are Jewish on IRL did anyone do a
breakdown on how many Christians come on
this show I am not a Christian but we
have a very very heavy disproportionate
amount of Christians who come on the
Show and Sheamus literally talking about
like sin and God and faith and stuff
regularly but nobody comes on be like
how come you have so much God love on
your show Tim and then Ian is some kind
of like he was what was he an atheist
it's not anymore I don't know he talks a
lot about God and the importance of it
but he's certainly not very seriously
he's elevated to a higher being now yeah
that's much higher yes well yeah I mean
that that's what happened I mean uh the
reason he's not here is because he
ascended to a higher Planet existence
right now yeah we're hoping he comes
back I hope so part of the reason for
that is it really is true that I think
if you have anything you know right of
you know what is now far left in society
which is now you know the Overton window
has shifted so far that what is normal
if you're anything to the right of that
you're challenged on a daily basis with
your media with the news that you and
you know that you choose to partake in
you're constantly having your viewpoints
checked because there are people that
you're going to be watching whether it's
on social media whether it's the news if
you're in an airport and you're watching
CNN whether it's the the television in
the movies you watch which are all at
the very least liberal Orthodoxy if not
left you know far left going further
left you're constantly being challenged
therefore you're forced to on a regular
basis is see the ideas of people you may
disagree with and that kind of hardens
your core to be able to take those
Concepts internalize them understand
what they're saying still understand
what your position on it is and either
make your argument back or just accept
that that person believes what they want
to believe and that's fine the people
that fall into the Dogma that is the
left now they get news that reaffirms
their beliefs they get movies that
reaffirm their beliefs they get music
that reaffirm their beliefs they aren't
really ever exposed to viewpoints that
they don't agree with and when they do
it's on social media and it becomes a
refast where they argue with you buy and
then and then they block you or they or
they turn off their mentions or since
you can't respond they get so destroyed
in a child they have to go to the
hospital
I mean that's that's that's another
great point that I didn't bring up to my
friend that I should have brought that
kid went to the hospital yeah poor guy
has did you see you saw that yeah that's
insane this it was a nuanced bro owned a
a leftist so hard he checked himself
into the emergency room to the ICU and
they gave him like an IV for for fluids
and stuff and what did I thought that
was a I thought it was fake he shouldn't
I thought he was joking he should have
never told that because now new one's
broken like wear that badge forever yeah
true there will be merch for that
for sure there will be I'm worried now
about having Nuance broke him in because
he might he might put us all in the
hospital you know I mean seriously
seriously hurt us with his men he should
sell risk like Hospital wristbands
you hear I'm sure someone can tell them
don't tell him yeah I survived a debate
with nuance
bro you get a hospital that's a
wristband that says I survived in the
basement
actually a really good merch idea that
would be great do it new ones bro come
on man yeah you got to do that man
that's good but it's kind of crazy that
he didn't he didn't actually do that
much he just told the kid he was wrong
well I mean he was so so dramatically
wrong and I like it kind of makes sense
why like if you think that's going on
which I can't imagine well for those of
none of the context the kid said that 30
of black people were being killed every
year by police
and he was like they would be gone in
three years there'd be no black people
left and it's that's crazy yeah and it's
because of you know it's because of the
The Narrative that comes out that again
is constantly shoved down people's
throat from the left and you people like
again like even LeBron James I brought
it up the other night he's talking about
you know we're hunted in the streets
it's like that is so far from true and
it's so hyperbolic that people it's no
wonder why there are like people that
are low information that are like man
I'm gonna die it's the streets of
Calabasas
if it was true that police were killing
30 of black people every year this show
would be called antifa IRL and that
would be one of the most I would one of
the most prolific organizers resisting
all of that and fighting to stop it it's
incredibly ridiculous I mean
but anyway so that's the context and
this kid ends up checking himself into a
hospital it's it's crazy because he
learned the world wasn't as bad as he
thought he even says is 15 to 20 fair
and they're like what no million
millions of people is not fair that's
just not fair millions of people being
shot and killed in the streets every
year innocent like not happening but he
genuinely thought that this is what
happens when these kids grow up in the
internet cult yeah and they think this
stuff and when you look this stuff up
even if you were to go to look up the
statistics you have to go four to five
like Pages down before you actually get
to any type of demographic data and
before that all you get is New York
Times articles Los Angeles Times
articles and they're all over the top
yeah and they all have the headlines
that we all know that are designed to
you don't even get past that you get to
the headline and you get scared and you
get angry and you don't actually look
for further information I'm just from
now on I'm gonna say that oh that was a
defect
so now if they're like didn't you see
that video of that guy and I'll be like
which one in the back that right-wing
guy that was a deep fake you didn't see
that that was fake that's just it's not
real anymore nothing's real you're wrong
deep fake sir my sources are real videos
your sources are all defects next
question yes that's actually a great
technique well because you know I'm
thinking I'm like in 10 years we won't
be having these conversations because
nothing will be real anymore yeah it'll
be it'll be AI doing it for us no no
it's not that it's that you wouldn't you
won't be able to know we're we're very
very close to the point where you just
can't know I mean do you guys see that
video that photograph of trump running
through DC with Sonic the Hedgehog like
was that real I can't tell I can't tell
no that was obviously obviously fake but
uh because Sonic didn't look real his
hair was off but um they should have
used the Sonic from the original design
from the movie that everybody hated so
much well I just asked mid journey to do
it I can't tell it to make it like use
bad Sonic man it's bad Sonic with the
weird teeth don't look up bad Sonic
either on on the internet that's a whole
nother thing that you don't know but but
my point is right now we still have the
ability to know what's true and what's
not but it's getting harder and we are
standing on the edge about to experience
something crazy
in a few years I think even next year
when there's 8 000 videos of trump doing
weird things and you can't tell if it's
real or fake it's gonna be hard thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there